I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh  Salam to the people of Marrakech Morocco  Prophet Allah what I care to welcome  here and we're here in New York when  you're in school New York City Union  Square Park the Union Square Park we're  usually in Haifa so basically guys I  wanted to invite you guys people are  here in New York or in their surrounding  areas that can make it here quickly we  talked to the bagels good on Wednesday  is 7th and Wednesday the 7th of November  from 6:00 to 9:00 tonight  until 9 o'clock I'm gonna be so  explosive I may even go past 9:00 it's  gonna be free entry today yes free entry  free parking inshallah physics an idea  16 amperes and a perform and Performing  Arts Center in York College in Jamaica  Queens New York the Trinity misto Heat